There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most hyped products
from September to test for ourselves.
I did it! I got my hands
on Clinique Black Honey.
Never did I imagine
a lipstick my mom wore back in the day
would go viral in 2021, but here we are.
This is a sheer lipstick-lip gloss hybrid
that has this just-bitten pink tint to it.
It supposedly looks great on everyone
because it blends with
your natural lip tone.
I really love this.
I feel like you can get the same effect
with one of those Burt's
Bee's tinted Chapsticks
at the drugstore that are, like, $5,
but the color of this is super beautiful,
and the formula is so
comfortable on the lips.
It's hydrating and has a nice slip to it.
About-Face is Halsey's makeup brand.
It just dropped these two new products,
the Fractal Glitter Eye Paint
and the Fractal Glitter Brow Gel.
Let's talk about the eye paint first.
I thought this packaging
was very cool and new,
like something I haven't seen before.
I don't know. It seemed fun.
And I love the color options
with these eye paints.
It was a good mix of neutrals
and more exciting colors.
I was worried these would dry quickly,
but I actually had no trouble
applying and blending them out.
They didn't get streaky or patchy,
but I will say the bolder colors,
like this blue one,
do need a second layer for full coverage.
If you're a one-and-done-
eye-shadow kind of person,
I think you'll like these.
Now let's talk about
the glitter brow gels.
Listen, I'm not going to pretend
that I'm interested in glitter brows,
but the products seem fun,
and I am interested in fun.
I'm actually obsessed
with the brush on this.
I really like how the
bristles brushed my brows.
However, it does deposit
a bit too much product.
You can see where I kind
of went outside the lines.
The actual glitter effect is cute,
if you're into that sort of thing.
I rubbed my brows to see
what the transfer situation is like,
and, surprisingly, the
hair seemed to stay put
and barely any glitter came off,
so I think the gel part of this product
works really well.
I do think that both of these products
are really overpriced for what they are,
but overall, I'm into this brand,
and I'm actually really excited to see
what they come out with next.
I feel like it's been
forever since we as a group
have been excited over a sponge,
and this one has been
getting amazing reviews.
This is the Real Techniques
Miracle Airblend Sponge.
I tried this wet and dry.
It doesn't expand very
much when you wet it,
but I liked it both ways.
I've never felt a sponge like this before.
It's completely weightless and squishy,
and because it's so
squishy, you can actually
really get into all those
crevices of your face.
I really love how my makeup
looked after using this.
It just looked really seamlessly blended.
I actually prefer this one way more
than the Real Techniques
original orange sponge.
The Nanoblur Instant Skin-Blurring Cream
was an experience.
I think I saw a TikTok that said
they use this on the set of "Euphoria"
to get rid of shininess.
So, it says you can use
it underneath makeup
and on top of makeup that
hasn't been set with powder yet,
so I tried it both ways.
It definitely mattifies,
but it leaves, like, a
white powdery cast behind.
I'm not sure if I put too much on or what.
My makeup started bunching
up between my brows
when I was blending my
foundation on top of it,
and it just looked bad.
Then I tried blending in a
small amount on my forehead
because I had some shine there,
and I feel like it did a little something,
but not enough for me
to ever use this again.
I just think it's too
matte on my bare skin
and pretty underwhelming on top of makeup,
so, yeah, I don't like this.
This is the weirdest
primer I've ever used.
This is the Smith & Cult
Untouched Skin Brightening
Foaming Face Primer.
I definitely overdid it
on my first application.
It wasn't blending in at all,
so I had to reapply it.
The foam actually feels
really nice on the skin,
and I swear it has, like,
this cooling sensation
that I really liked. It felt good.
It's a nice first step to your makeup.
It certainly does brighten.
I looked like a Victorian ghost woman.
I feel like this almost
lightened my foundation.
I get that it's brightening,
but I didn't think it
would make my foundation
a shade lighter. I had
to mix in a deeper shade.
I do think my makeup looked nice
on top of this primer,
but I'm just not into the
brightening aspect of it.